Problemen till en dålig arbetsmiljö på arbetsplatsen, jag tror på riktigt att det beror på att det finns för många mellan chefer som har egna ägande, 100%.
Och framförallt i icke-ägareledda bolag.
Och det är ju så de flesta arbetsplatserna ser ut.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Daniel Björnmalm till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Daniel är ju en av grundarna och ägarna till Bolaget Relevant, som kanske inte alla människor känner till, men som står bakom en mängd intressanta och häftiga varumärken.
Men man är ju lite sådär en gogubbe från västkusten som lyckats hålla sig gömd för de stora Break-It-tidningarna.
Och det tycker jag är lite häftigt när man driver många hundra miljonsbolag.
Är det en uttalad strategi skulle du säga?
Ja, det får man väl lov att säga.
Vi är ju i stort inte riktade mot slutkonsumenter.
Så vi håller ju oss i vårat lilla område inom våran bransch.
Vilket gör att det har blivit ganska givet att vi inte är så synliga för den stora massan.
Men ni sitter här och taktar på någonstans runt eller norr om 300 miljoner år efter år efter år.
Det gör vi och det har varit en liten platå de senaste åren.
Jag tror det är rätt få människor som kan känna igen sig i den.
Kan du inte berätta bara lite kort vad ni gör eftersom ni är som sagt lite dolda?
Ja, men absolut.
Vi är en distributör inom sport, häls och lifestyle.
Och som säljer, marknadsför och bygger varumärken på den nordiska och den baltiska marknaden.
Sedan dessutom så har vi dotterbolag i Frankrike sedan 2019 och i Benelux sedan 2018 som också förser de marknaderna med våra plukter.
Det är en sån där presentation som gör att man inte har någon koll alls.
Men du kanske kan ta några av de varumärken ni jobbar med, för de tror jag faktiskt att folk har rätt bra koll på.
Jo men absolut.
Vår tanke och vår röda tråd sedan start egentligen har varit att vi ska förse våra marknader med produkter inom, som först var uppkopplad sport-
och hälsorelaterade produkter, men också som blev lite analoga produkter.
Och sen har vi utökat det även med ett ben som vi kallar för lifestyle.
Men om vi tittar på varumärkena som vi har i den delen som är den stora för oss, som har hängt med oss sen vi var ett embryo.
Så några varumärken som vi jobbar med är Wahoo, som är indoor trainers, bland de största i världen på det, cykulatorer, andra hjälpmedel för cyklister.
Widdings, som är ett franskt varumärke med uppkopplade vågar, blodtrycksmätare, klockor och annat.
Tänker lite annorlunda än alla de andra stora broadlinerserna.
Sarabadi som är pionjärer och välsledande inom återrämtning.
Både kompliktionsbyxor och massagepistoler och hela den.
Den delen av det är Morten som är hydrohjälf från ett Göteborgsföretag som är väldigt, väldigt stort.
För oss också.
Kåros som är löpaklocker som är det snabbast växande varumärket i världen inom denna kategori nu.
Vi har Reclaim som är ett trettmedel som tar bort och dör.
Och Lucent som är tandhälsa kan man säga där.
Och sen har vi Lifestylebenet då som är lite mer riktat åt det alldagliga livet.
Det är ett fint varumärke som vi har jobbat med sedan 2019 och det är Marshall.
Så där är vi deras exklusiva distributör för Norden och Baltikum.
Och det är ju högtalare och höllurare då, framförallt.
Har ni följt hela den här resan med försäljningar?
Det har vi gjort, absolut.
Och det har ju varit en intressant resa.
Alltifrån att de köpte sin licensgivare i USA, då den gamla onerika gitarrförstärker, koncernen Marshall.
Och nu då nyligen där hela den koncernen såldes till ett kinesiskt investmentbolag.
Så att det har hänt mycket bakom scenerna men jag skulle säga att businessen är as usual.
Och det är samma människor och samma typ av affärer och business som vi gör där.
Och utöver det så jobbar vi med Pure som kanske låter lite konstigt i vår nisch, men det är elsparkcyklar som ägs av, om man är lite insatt i formulett, så ägs de i hela det bolaget av Land & Norris pappa Adam Norris.
De har även brett samarbete med McClaren och de ligger också väldigt hukt uppe i både design, utveckling och väldigt annorlunda tänkt.
Och det var det som triggade oss och dessutom tog vi över den befintliga affären nere i Frankrike som var av en bra size på det där.
Är det det som sammanfattar alla de här varumärkena att de ligger ganska högt i kvalitet eller designspråk?
Man kan säga att det, du har helt rätt i den analysen, de varumärkena vi jobbar med, till början kan man säga att vi har alltid sagt att vi ska inte jobba med mer än 15 aktiva varumärken för vi vill vara den förlängda armen från våra tillverkare.
Det hade varit oerhört lätt för oss att öppna upp 50 varumärken, men det är kostsamt och det kräver ett engagemang och det går inte att vara lika mycket inne i de bitarna där.
Men i stort sett, samtliga utav våra varumärken är världsledande inom deras respektive kategorier.
Det har också varit anledning till att vi har klarat oss väldigt bra genom de lite tuffare tiderna som har varit här nu.
Innan vi har hög konjunktur så jobbar åtförsäljaren oftast med deras unbrand.
Det kommer de alltid att göra och det är en viktig drivare in till de här kategorierna för oss.
Sen fanns det ofta plats för ett varumärke som ligger någonstans i midrange-delen och sedan ett A-brand som ligger där uppe.
Det vi har sett är att det blir väldigt trångt och de spelar mycket safe under de åren som har varit nu, vilket gör att oftast så ramlar mittensegmentet lite bort.
Så de fokuserar på sitt egna varumärke och fokuserar på ett till varumärke och det är oftast ett A-brand.
Det är i princip bara den typen av varumärke som vi har.
Det är också en tacksam slutkund i vårt perspektiv.
Det är oftast en man eller kvinna någonstans ganska högt upp i karriären, 35-50 år.
Som inte är så konjunkturkänslig heller.
Så jag tror att det är en ganska bra strategi där.
Och inom lifestylebenet där också så jobbar vi med Steamerie och Stockholm som är ett gäng designade steamers som är också ett fint varumärke.
Man kanske inte disklosar sådant men vi säljer ju Oahu från er och det var ju ett sånt där varumärke där det var inte ni som hade av er till oss och det var egentligen inte vi som hade tänkt att ha av oss till er heller men vi hade ju kunder som liksom låg på och ville ha det här varumärket och tyckte att kan ni inte ta in det så vi kan köpa det från er också.
Min känsla är att ni har lite den sortens varumärken där det finns ett kundtryck på återförsäljaren att ta in det.
Är det korrekt uppfattat?
Ja men så är det absolut.
Wahoo är ett väldigt roligt exempel på hur vi har växt upp tillsammans.
Martin, min andra medgrundare till bolaget, hade ett call med Chip Hawkins som grundade Wahoo ungefär samtidigt när vi drog igång 2012.
Och då satt Martin hemma i sin soffa och han satt hemma i sin soffa.
Vi var precis i startgroparna till våra respektive bolag.
Och vi har verkligen växt tillsammans och vi är, om inte den största så är vi den näst största distributören i världen för Wahoo idag.
Och absolut är det så att det är en kategoriprodukter som är väldigt eftertraktad från både åtverkäljare och slutkunder överallt.
Och där har vi ju en, det är en viktig strategi för oss att ha en vettig strategi när det kommer till vad vi väljer att göra på marknaden.
Vi har olika distributörsstrategier för olika varumärken.
Men så är det absolut.
Så det är inte alla som kan eller får eller bör sälja en indoor trainer som gärna hade velat göra.
Nu dyker vi ju bara rakt in här i de lite tyngre frågorna direkt.
Men det är ju för att det är intressant.
Så vi skiter lite i lite andra småfrågor och vi kanske kommer tillbaka till dem.
Men vad är det som får de här varumärkena att börja jobba med?
För att ni sitter ju här i Bildal.
Och min fördom i alla fall är att stora varumärken dras till stora logistikhubbar eller storstäder i alla fall.
Eller väldigt stora distributionskonglomerat.
Men ni har ju fantastiskt fina varumärken.
Och även om alla inte känner till alla varumärkena inom träningsbranschen så vet väl de flesta vad Marshall är i alla fall.
Så kortsiktigt, vad är det som gör att de här varumärkena vill jobba med er?
Jag tror att vi måste backa bandet lite grann.
Jag har varit i konsumentelektronisk bransch i hela mitt yrkesverksamma liv.
Jag har haft två anställningar hela mitt liv.
Dagen efter studenten så fick jag fast anställning på Siba.
Där var jag i fyra och ett halvt år.
En fantastisk skola.
En otroligt rolig arbetsplats som det var då.
Sen blev jag lockad över till andra sidan.
Jag var väldigt bra på att hantera slutkunder.
Med det hade jag gått självförtroende när man hoppade över och skulle jobba på andra sidan i en annan diskutörsverksamhet, en dansk ägd, vilket var också en nyttig erfarenhet att jobba i ett danskt koncern.
Det är ganska olikt hur vi tänker i Sverige.
Men framförallt kanske personalpolitik, hur man ser det är väldigt rak kommunikation.
Man lindar inte in någonting och det kan bli väldigt obehagligt för oss svenskar som försöker hålla en lite annan nedtonad del på det.
När jag kom dit så fick jag nog en chock för jag trodde jag var jävligt bra och så var jag helt ur-usel när man kom dit och kände att fy fan ska jag kunna hantera återförsäljare snarare än slutkunder.
Men det gav sig efter en period där och det var en väldigt rolig resa.
Jag är jättetacksam för de tio åren som jag hade där, där jag fick förmånen väldigt tidigt och ta över som vd.
Så jag började som säljare och tog över som flyttade upp mig som kan efter några 1,5-2 år eller någonting sånt där.
Sedan fick jag prova på en sverigeschefsroll.
Sedan efter ett år så tog jag över som vd.
Då var jag 27 år och hade ingen erfarenhet överhuvudtaget i detta.
Då hade en konstig chef som lovade att komma upp och lotsa mig genom den här miljön och jag tror han var uppe en gång.
Det är sann dansk.
Det lärde mig jävligt mycket ska jag säga.
Det var inte helt lätt första styrelsemötet att veta vad jag skulle prata om där nere.
Det var att slänga sig in i de bitarna där.
Men i och med det så skapade man mycket relationer och mycket kontaktytor överallt såklart.
Jag kan väl lika gärna lite grann gå in här nu då från anledningen till oss och anledningen till Relevant egentligen.
Jag hade varit där i tio år och hade kommit upp i en omsättning till runt 150-160 miljoner.
Jag anställde en affärsutvecklare för att titta på lite nya möjligheter och det var Martin Lilligren då, min andra delägare och grundare till Relevant.
Han var den som identifierade det här hela delen med sportelektronik.
Detta var 2012, det var i Blåtan 4 det precis kommit, man började koppla upp prylar mot sin telefon.
Väldigt tidigt dock.
Men han hittade ett par varumärken som är intressanta och jag tyckte att jag brann för det här.
För de övriga produkterna vi sålde, det var mer datortillbehör på den tiden, vilket kanske inte var supersexigt, men det var roligt ändå.
Men det här var produkter som jag kände att jag brann för.
Så vi gjorde ett litet arbete inför ett styrelsemöte och presenterade hela den här idén, att det här blir vår väg fram för hela koncernen.
Jag fick väl ett ganska svalt mottagande på den delen, de tyckte att vi kunde driva detta som ett litet hobbyprojekt uppe i Sverige för att se vart det leder.
Och då blev jag, jag kände mig lite producerad för jag trodde så mycket på detta.
Så dagen efter så tog jag in Martin i ett konferenser och sa att nu skiter vi här, vi skjuter ut oss och vi tar och drar igång en egen verksamhet istället.
Och jag menar, vi var två pöjkar som kände att det här var rätt väg att gå.
Och när Martin, när jag hade haft det snacket där så tänkte jag, fan jag måste ju ta detta med frugan också, som var hemma med och var mammaledig över det här tidpunkten.
Det här med perfekt timing att starta bolag, det har nog aldrig någonsin hänt i historien tror jag.
Så jag tänkte, hur fan ska jag göra detta då?
Så jag skrev ett jordens längsta sms hem till Charlotte, min dåvarande sambo, gifta sen många år.
Och förklarade hur jag kände att det här är ett kallig och måste göra det här.
Jag vågar inte ta det in face med henne.
Så det blev ett långt sms och efter typ fem minuter fick jag tillbaka.
Vilket var såklart jättehärligt.
För det blev ju såklart en lite annan tillvaro då.
Från att ha haft ett bra jobb och tryggare ekonomi till att slänga sig ut i någonting som vi överhuvudtaget inte visste något om.
Det var ganska tydligt när vi drog igång det här och vi skulle köra första åren.
Jag menar vi visste ingenting om.
Jag hade drivit några andra småbolag tidigare.
Men jag var faktiskt e-handelspionjär får man säga.
I 2004 drog vi igång, jag och min fru eller sambor då, dels ett automatisk odotek nere i Eriksberg, men också en ICOM 2004.
Det var väldigt, väldigt tidigt.
Charlotte jobbade då på Jet Shop, som var en av de leverantörerna till e-handelsplattformar.
Så vi drog igång en sexsleksaks-business.
Män riktad enbart mot kvinnor.
Det hette Seven Senses.
Nu när jag ser tillbaks på det så hade vi fortsatt på den linjen så hade det förmodligen...
Det var för tidigt.
Men vi hade ingenting riktad mot män, utan bara kvinnor.
Väldigt nedtonad design på alla de bitarna.
Så det var en väldigt rolig del.
Men i och med att jag fick möjligheten att ta över som vd på det andra bordet, kände jag att det här rimmar inte.
Jag fick ju leveranser till lageret på det andra med de här grejerna.
Det har ibland varit några praktikanter där att titta och det blev lite märkligt så.
Så det var verkligen en sida och affär på det.
Om man ska tänka grejer som verkligen funkar inom e-handel, så är ju det en grej som...
Så är det.
Vi drev den ändå i två och ett halvt tre år och jag har nog aldrig varit med om någonting där det varit så lite är det måhantering.
Det var rätt skönt.
Och de få som kom gick direkt till papperskorgen så kan man säga.
Men det var en rolig del i det hela.
Men vart var det någonstans?
Jag pratar bort mig.
Men det vi hade ju bra, det som vi kom fram till, Martin, det var att vi har förövrigt en otroligt okomplicerad fördelning i 50-50 när det gäller till återriva affärer, vilket faktiskt inte har varit ett enda problem för oss under de här, vad det nu blir, tretton åren som vi har blivit där.
Och vi har fungerat väldigt, väldigt bra ihop och vi har kompletterat varandra.
Jag är mer CEO-rollen.
Jag älskar att överblicka affären och titta på siffror och nörda ner mig lite grann i de bitarna, medans Martin är mer utåt, mer marknadseriktad.
Jag ska helst inte ha med marknadsordelingen att göra, för saker jag inte kan ta på, där ska jag hålla mig ifrån.
Jag försöker hålla mig ifrån marknadsordelingen, för den blir...
Det är bara så.
Men vi drog igång där och vi, framförallt när vi tittade på vilka kunder vi hade en historik bakom, så var det som att sätta Jing och Yang bredvid varandra.
De kontakterna och kunder som jag hade drivit genom alla år i den här branschen, var inte de som Martin hade, utan det var precis tvärtom.
Så vi kompletterade enda otroligt bra där.
Sedan hade vi ett nätverk som var bra.
Framförallt hjälpte det oss mycket i början, där många var mer av barmhärtighetsskäl, köpte prylar av oss, snarare än att det här kommer nog bli bra.
Men varumärkena var ju det som är the reason why.
Jag glömde faktiskt att jag skulle ta med den in hit.
För det var väldigt roligt att du är här hos oss idag, i våra lokaler.
Men det var en actionkamera som hette Liquid Image, som faktiskt var vid denna tidpunkten, längre fram rent tekniskt än Go Pro.
Det var den som möjliggjorde hela den här igångsättningen av Relevant.
Men i övrigt på den här tiden, så är det fortfarande viktigt med NCS-mässan i Las Vegas varje januari, och IFA-mässan i Berlin i september.
De är viktiga tillfällen där dels att vi kan visa att vi är där för branschen, men också vi är där och kan träffa potentiella leverantörer och tillverkare.
På den här tiden så, pengar var billigt, innovationen var stor, det kom mycket varumärken hela tiden.
Vi kunde komma hem med 8-9 varumärken potentiella som vi hade fått kontakt med på golvet på mässgolven.
Det var ju tufft i början, det är klart att när du är nystartad och inte har speciellt mycket track record, det är inte så att det bara rasslar in nya stora varumärken till en.
Utan det är ett hårt jobb som krävs, och det jobbet gjorde vi ordentligt.
När ni kom igång här med Relevant och ni skulle sätta igång, vad är det varumärket letar efter?
Det är det som gör, skulle jag säga, att vi hade en ganska unik approach från början.
Vi hade en idé om att samla dels hela denna kategorin produkter under ett tak, vilket var väldigt bra för varumärkena för att se att de blir samlad med andra som inte konkurrerar med varandra.
Men också att vi var, jag skulle nog vilja påstå att vi var bland de första i Europa som servade både konsumenterligt teknik och sportbranschen.
Sportbranschen är ju väldigt traditionell och det är mycket säsongsköp.
Helt annat tänk var det på denna tiden, speciellt med lågmarginalprodukter som det ändå är inom teknik.
Så det var en liten uppförspack i början men vi sydde ihop detta och gjorde bra affärer med sportbranschen, vilket var en trigger för många av varumärkena, att vi nådde ut på denna tiden till de bitarna.
Sen är det så att vi har en pallett med servicera.
Jag skulle vilja påstå att vi ändå är ganska, vi står ut bland våra konkurrenter.
Att vara normalt sett en distributör, ja du flyttar brandboxers liksom, det är det som man konventionellt sett har gjort.
Men vi är så mycket mer än det.
Vi jobbar med en pallett med service gentemot våra leverantörer och sen kan de välja vad de vill ha hjälp med.
Det kan vara alltifrån, vi gör en heltidsanställd som är ut och genomför utbildningar, mässor och event.
Vi gör över hundra event per år.
Det kan vara alltifrån mindre butiksevent till att vi är stora samarbetspartner, till bland annat Göteborgsvarvet i form av Mårten som är ett av våra vårmärken.
Det kan vara kvällar, temakvällar på en cykelbutik, eller vi kan stå och visa och dema grejer på Vasaloppet och annat.
Så vi är ju ut väldigt mycket och det kan vi göra för dem.
Vi kan driva PR på de marknader som vi är i, och vi driver både kanalmarknadsföring och generell marknadsföring för dem.
Och vi kan och har möjligheten och gör också driver deras nordiska ICOM-verksamheter.
Vi driver våra vårmärken.sc.no.dk och de bitarna, vilket blir ett verktyg för oss när vi bygger vårmärkena, och framförallt ett sätt för oss att nå ut med full sortiment.
Det är långt ifrån alla som kan ha ett brett sortiment av alla vårmärken vi har där.
Så att delt beroende på, jag menar tittar man på Marshall, som ändå är ett Stockholmsbaserat företag, så har ju de mycket av sin lösning på plats redan.
Så där hjälper vi inte till med marknadsföring eller de bitarna så mycket, men däremot så är vi en bred försäljningspartner till dem då.
Medan då Vahoo, där vi gör allt, där driver vi i Com, där driver vi RPR, marknadsföring i alla event och alla de bitarna.
Så då är det liksom en annan typ av package.
Och det skulle jag säga är en, det är nog en väldigt unik styrka för oss tror jag.
Och att vi är väldigt flexibla, vi är nära till beslut.
Det är jag och Martin som äger bolaget, vi har inte tagit in någon externt kapital någon gång.
Vi har byggt verksamheten brick by brick, från det vi kunde låna upp på husen vid den tidpunkten på 250 000 var.
Och det är också någonting som vi är väldigt stolta över, men det är också någonting som gör att vi har kunnat ta snabba beslut och snäva svängar.
För det har ju varit tillfällen där det har varit extremt tufft under den här resan.
Många gånger som det har gått på gott helvete.
Men man har väl ingen verksamhet om den inte har varit nära konkursen tre, fyrsta gången i tänkleden.
Jag kan tycka att det är ganska sällan som man lyssnar på distributörer i mediasammanhang.
Ofta pratar man ju med Återvskäljan eller så pratar man med brandet eller någonting annat.
Men vad är, men vad är er liksom svårigheterna för er och vad är er existensberättigande?
Det är också en bra fråga.
Vi är ju lite grann stack in between.
Vi blir ju nedtryckt av leverantörerna och vi blir påtryckta av våra återvskäljare.
Så vi är ju lite grann i ett skruvstäd.
Men hanterar man det på ett bra sätt så går det väldigt bra.
Jag menar man kan titta på att vara ett varumärke så har du oftast en, det är en helt annan, om man tittar på en värdering på ett bolag, men ett varumärke är ju en helt annan möjlighet att värdera.
Kanske en disbutörsverksamhet som lever på avtal som löper.
Däremot är det så att får ett leverantör eller tillverkare eller varumärke problem, då sitter det ett problem.
Vi kan parera det genom att se vad som händer på marknaden, vad kan vi titta fram mot, vad händer om ett och ett halvt, två år, är det några trender vi kan plocka upp redan nu, vi kan titta på att byta ut varumärken.
Där finns det en flexibilitet som är ganska skön, att man kan fokusera dit det just nu fungerar.
Om man tittar på återhämtningsdelen exempelvis, där vi var med när massagsbistolen total boomade 2019-2020, där vi sålde massagsbistolen för 70 miljoner, tills att hela den kategorin bara tvär dog efter all flooding från Kina av diverse crap.
Så har vi haft uthållighet med den delen och kunnat fokusera på allt annat under den här tiden och nu är vi i en uppbyggnad fas, tillsammans med TheraBody, de är ändå världsledande inom den här kategorin och den växer kraftigt nu.
Men det behövdes komma till den här punkten att explosion och total utrensning och sen återuppbyggnads fas då, i princip 2.0 då.
Så det är ju en del och när vi kommer till existensberättningarna så är det ju en bra fråga.
För det finns ju alltid risk för oss om vi gör saker och ting för bra.
För då kan ju det trigga en tillverkare till att ta den affären direkt då.
Samtidigt är det så här att vi agerar främst här i Norden.
Vi kör våra dotterbolag i Frankrike och Benelux och de bitarna.
Men tittar man på den nordiska verksamheten så är det att det är komplicerat för en tillverkare att driva en affär här.
Vi är fyra länder, det är fyra språk, fyra valutor.
Det är en komplex jävla logistikkädja och det är ett land utanför EU.
Det är inte en drum.
Så det gör att vi, man ska aldrig säga att man sitter safe, men är det någonstans som det är ändå otroligt att någon väljer att ta det steget, åtminstone av våra varumärken, så är det väl ändå i Norden då.
Frankrike är ju en liten, där får man brottas betydligt mer för att, och då måste vi spela på alla våra styrkor som vi har där nere, som inte någon annan har eller en leverantör kan tänkas ha då.
Men här är det, jag skulle ändå vilja påstå att det är många som säger att distributörsdöden är här och att, det ser jag nog mer in inom konfession skulle jag säga, att det börjar ramla bort mer och mer.
Men i vår bransch, där vi ser med den typen av produkter, med eftermarknad och hantering och alla sådana grejer, så tror jag att vi är safe i alla fall under den nästa framtiden.
Hur mycket kontakt har ni med varumärkena för att liksom känna in deras språk?
Blir ni på något sätt deras brandcontrollers här?
Eller hur funkar det där?
Absolut, vi har jättetätt kommunikation med alla våra leverantörer.
Jag vill gärna se, det som är viktigt för oss också när det kommer till de olika varumärkena, vi är ett people's company.
Vi jobbar primärt på magkänsla.
Vi måste ha en bra känsla för människorna vi jobbar med.
Och vi har en väldigt, väldigt nära relation med alla våra varumärken.
Vi sitter med uppföljningsmöten, strategimöten och även marknadsmöten tillsammans med deras marknadsavdelningar för att sätta strategierna.
Det är inte så att de bara lämnar oss och sen, vi hörs om ett år och ser hur det har gått, utan det är ett gediget arbete som görs från våra marknadsavdelning tillsammans med våra leverantörer.
Så att det är en, för de som vill ha den hjälpen då, det beror på lite grann, men vi gör det här arbetet ganska brett för de flesta av våra varumärken som vi jobbar med.
Hur ser er urvalsprocess ut när det gäller återförsäljare, eller vem som ska sälja varumärket?
Hur ser den dialogen ut?
I dag är det ju, på så sätt sitter vi...
Vi vill ju pressa priser mot kunder, det blir ju lite anti-klimax.
Så är det, och det är en jättesvår balans.
Vi har ju ingen möjlighet att gå in och påverka i större grad hur en prissättning sker.
Men däremot är det ju så här att vi, som jag sa där, vi har alltid en strategi kring hur vi skulle vilja se bredden på antal återkäljare.
Vi har väl den lyxen ska jag säga nu, det har inte alltid varit så såklart, men idag jagar ju vi inte så mycket nya leverantörer.
Vi blir ju kontaktade väldigt mycket, men vi har väldigt höga krav idag på hur en leverantör ska vara om vi ska ta upp en ny leverantör.
Men även kunderna vi jobbar med, jag skulle säga 99 procent av alla de kunderna som finns på våra marknader, jobbar vi med idag i varierande djuphet.
Så det är lite upp till oss att sätta en strategi där hur vi vill se de olika varumärken ska vara exponerade och vi vet ju att vissa gånger går det inte att ha samma produkt hos två åtfällare som vi vet är riktiga krigare mot varandra.
Med det sagt så är det ju en, jag menar man får försöka ha en öppen dialog, kommunikation om saker och ting.
Alla i den här branschen i syvende och sist för att ha sina marginalkronor.
Det är ju viktigt, det är ju egentligen inget som vill hålla på att kriga mot en totalt intetgörande marginaler.
Men det är tufft så är det ju.
Och vi har minimala möjligheter att gå in och påverka där.
Hamnar ni ofta i konflikt med återförsäljare kring det där?
Ja, både ja och nej, nej, det skulle jag inte säga.
Mycket av diskussionerna är väl ofta kring det här.
Det är ju en vardag för alla, det är en vardag för dig men jag förmodar.
Ja, så jag skulle inte säga att det är någonting som tar för mycket tid.
Men det är klart att frågan ofta kommer upp.
Hur ofta har du det här samtalet när du ringer en återförsäljare som har ringt till varumärket och sagt att jag säljer mycket av er produkt, att jag kan ta över agenturen?
Det händer.
Nä, men våra leverantörer har ju så djupa samarbeten så vi får ju alltid reda på det.
Det blir ju lite oskönt då.
Det är faktiskt främst de danska kunder som kör den linjen och det hänger lite samman med deras företagskultur.
Vem är det som ringer samtalet?
Hur menar du det där?
Det är ingen som ringer och säger att ni får backa undan här.
Nej, det löser sig själv, vi går aldrig in.
Det är lite onödigt att gå in i den delen.
Oftast svarar leverantören, eller tillverkaren och varumärket, att vi är väldigt, väldigt döjna med vår situation och så får vi en liten heads-up och så suckar vi lite och så tänker jag att de har försökt men det finns ingen mening för oss och det blir en onödig konflikt men de vet nog förmodligen att vi vet ändå.
Men vi lägger ingen onödig energi på det, tänker jag.
Vi nämnde ju lite här, ni hade ju en ganska linjär resa i början.
Jag älskar att du ser så sammanbiten ut inför den här frågan.
Nej det är det såklart inte.
Jag menar, det är en, vi avslutade förra året faktiskt på strax under 400, så nu är vi lite grann i tillväxtfas igen.
Det hände väldigt mycket 2019 för oss, innan covid slog till.
På den tiden var det ju, inte för att överdriva, men det var ju jävligt mycket enklare att driva en business på den tiden.
Man visste hur valutan såg ut, man visste ju vad det kostade att ta hem någonting logistikmässigt, och det var inte så mycket handelshinder liksom, det var mest att fokusera på CWK verksamhet.
Idag är det ju tommefant.
Det är ju stora jävla obstiklösa, precis överallt var man än tittar någonstans.
Men det hände mycket då och vi blev, det var en väldigt rolig grej som hände.
Vi blev nominerade till Entrepreneur of the Year och kom med i finaldelen i Västra Götaland och Halland, bland de tio bidragen där och det var ju en, det gav ju lite självförtroende och det gav en liten ego boost såklart, som nu i efterhand kanske, ja men, det är lätt att sitta i denna och svepas med i det här och kanske, jag ska inte säga bli cocky men det är klart att man, det var det ena och det andra och vi, vi fick väl någon fråga i någon gammal intervju som inte har aged so well, tycker jag där att, men vad är er att måla?
Ja vi ska nå upp till miljarden och det, det blir alltid lite fånigt med sådana uttalande, när man ligger på de här kanske 250-300 och de bitarna.
Visst vi hade väl saker och ting som vi såg där.
Jag menar idag, det är fem år sedan, man ser på saker lite mer nyktigt, lite mer ödmjukt.
Och tänker att, ja men, vi har inte nåt uttalat mål att, ja men om det är året och det ska vi omsätta en miljard liksom, utan vi ser hellre att växa lönsamt och lite långsammare.
Men med det sagt så har vi bra vindesteglen nu och det har en, vi har kommit ur de här två tuffåren.
2023 var vi i vårt första förlustår.
Inte mycket men det var ändå, det var lust ändå rutt på sista raden och det var ju tråkigt liksom.
Men nu är vi tillbaks på ytterligare normala nivåer och i år tror jag nog faktiskt med, ganska så säkert att vi kommer att passera en halv miljard.
Och det är såklart jätteroligt, men med det sagt så vi sätter inga långsiktiga strategier på om då ska vi vara där och uppborda de bitarna, för det är nej, vi har lämnat den.
Hur tror du att den här gamla Daniel hade sett det nu när han belånade huset där för 250 000 och så tittar han framåt nu och ser när du sitter och säger att vi försöker ta det lite lugnt här nu, vi börjar med en halv miljard.
Ja det är klart att det blir, men man får inte heller glömma att vi är i distributionsledet, det är ju betydligt större.
Jag menar att vårt snittorder är ju väldigt väldigt stor.
Jag ska inte lägga någon skugg över det vi har gjort men det är ju betydligt svårare att komma upp i de nivåerna om du har jobbat direkt mot slutkunder exempelvis, så att det, hittar man rätt så kan det gå väldigt väldigt fort.
Så är det ju.
Jag kan fatta det, vi har inte alls samma snittordekvitto som ni har men vi har ju också ett rätt högt snittordekvitto.
Jag kan fascineras av de här som säljer ett läppstift för 100-200 spänn och så frågar de hur många ordrar har ni om dagen och så säger vi 80.
Och så bara inser man att ni har ju 5.000 ordrar om dagen, det är en jävla logistik.
Ja och så är det ju, jag menar logistikdelen är väldigt bra.
Vi har ju valt att outsourca lagedelen, vi har 3PL-lösning på det vilket vi är väldigt nöjda med.
Vi brinner inte för att driva en logistik eller lagerverksamhet och då är det bättre att vi fokuserar på det som vi brinner för och tycker är väldigt roligt.
Sedan tror jag att vi har lyckats med detta också, tror jag, genom att vi var tvingade att klara saker och ting.
Vi har ju stått i vägval under de här åren att välja vilken väg vi ska gå.
Ska vi ta in pengar eller ska vi inte göra det?
Vi valde att gå vägen med Nischbank de första, vad det nu blir, fem åren.
Det är en kostsam del med betydligt högre ränta, men de tar lite större risker och det var rätt väg för oss att gå.
Jag kan bara dra upp två händelser som anledningen till att jag tror att vi klarar det så bra är att vi var tvingade att göra det.
Vi snurrar vårdlagen någonstans runt 11 gånger per år, vilket är väldigt bra om man tittar på den typen av verksamhet som vi har.
Men det har också hängt samman med att det finns ingen backup.
Vi har bara vårt kapital att jobba med och vårt cashflow att jobba med och då kan vi inte bara för skojskuld bygga ett enormt lager och bara för att säkra upp lite grann där.
Och jag tror att vårt pannben genom åren har väl gjort att...
Jag kan ju bara dra en historia från 2016.
Då jobbade vi med ett varumärksamheter Jobon som var huvudkonkurrent i Fitbit på den tiden med stegräknare och de bitarna.
Då var det glödhett.
Vi jagade både Fitbit och Jobon och av olika anledningar.
Så 2014 så landade vi med ett avtal med Jobon och det är skavde från början.
Vi hade ett möte och jag kände att det här är ingen bra magkänsla.
Men vi körde på för det var så viktigt för oss.
Mer än tredubblad omsättning till det året 2016 omsatte vi väl 69 miljoner varav 58 procent var Jobon.
Vi levde väldigt väldigt väldigt farligt då.
Och vad som hände var att det blev en enorm krasch på grund av att de satte två nya produkter på marknaden som var helt ingjutna i gummi.
Produkten i sig var flåless, var inga problem alls.
Problemet var bara att det uppkom här uppe först i Norden.
När det blev kallt så gick gummit sönder.
Och det gick inte att laga.
För den var ju integrerad i tekniken.
Och när vi började rapportera detta till Jobon borta i USA och sa att det är någonting som är fel här, det blir en...
Det är enormt många RMA-förfrågningar på Jobon-abandon och att gummitspricker de bara.
Nej det är ingenting vi har sett, det måste bara vara en liten del.
Men sen totalt exploderat.
I stort sett 100% av alla de produkterna gick i sönder.
Och vi stod där med ansvaret gentemot marknaden.
Och Jobon klarade inte det så de gick i konkurs.
Vi blev av med 59% av vår omsättning och blev ståendes med kostnader på nästan 5 miljoner kronor som vi var tvungna att stå för till våra åtfällare.
Då var det jävla med skallt läge, då var det liksom, okej vad gör vi då?
Vi förlängde verksamhetsåret med ytterligare 6 månader, vi gick ut och hade möte med alla våra kunder och förklarade att vi har liksom en och en halv miljon eget kapital, det här klarar inte vi.
Men med bra dialog och lite avbetalningsplaner och sen ett idrottsjagande av nya varumärken som i princip bara fick hjälpa oss upp av de här bitarna, så löste vi fan det per egen maskin.
Att komma upp i samma omsättning på nästa kommande 18 månaderna som vi gjorde de tidigare, 12, och hittade en nya ben att stå på.
Det var väl det yttersta provet på något sätt.
Det var inte läge att ta in pengar eller det hade blivit bra med 90% av bolaget bara att överleva.
Då var dina unga fyra, fem år.
Jag som själv har kraschat, hur mordde du under den där perioden egentligen?
Det var fruktansvärt, jag tappade så mycket hår.
Jag hade en 1,5-åring och en 5-åring och en 1,5-åring.
Det var enormt tufft.
Det var vi, jag åldrades mycket under de åren.
Där kan man säga.
Så det var en tuff period.
Och som lite grann då, precis efter detta hände så kom vi i kontakt med ett annat varumärke som vi kände också direkt att det är något lite som inte jämten hade med oss att göra men vi kände att vi körde.
Det var, man kan säga att vi grävde en ny grupp.
Och det är ju en gammal, gammalt beprövat koncept men jag skulle också säga att den var nog en väldigt stor del.
Alltså det var, nej vi var jävligt ju djupt ner alltså.
Ja men vi såg att okej det här det var ju som en quick fix liksom.
Nu har vi möjligheten att rädda det här som räddas kan då.
Lite grann så och detta var en Star Wars drönare.
Alltså faktum var att produkten i sig var helt, den var grym den också.
I grund och bort var det inget fel på produkten.
Det var den mest besökta monten på CS-mässan det året 2017.
Vi hade lite tidigare kontakter som gjorde att den dörren öppnades och vi körde igång.
Jag har aldrig varit med om att åka runt på en införsäljningsturné men alla de stora åtförsäljarna där alla bara gör vågen och säger hur många får vi köpa.
Det var ett koncept som var fantastiskt.
Du hade en app-styrning på, du kunde övningsköra i den, du var uppkopplat till Disney, du kunde köra laserfights mot varandra.
Kontrollen var i stort sett av DJI-känsla, det var en stor kraftig, den kostade 2.500 ut någonstans där.
Vi bara dundrade och körde och då skulle vi ha tävlingar på alla Disney, det skulle vara semifinaler och finaler i Disney World och vi skulle vinna en miljon dollar, den som blir mest du vet.
Det var ett sånt paket som kom där och lagom till jul, säsong och alla de bitarna.
Det blev lovat guld och grönsko.
Jag tror vi sålde in 15.000 drönare på den nordiska marknaden.
När den väl blir release så visar det sig att de inte hade koll på rättigheterna på spel och uppkopplade delen.
Electronic Arts hade 100% rättigheter på alla spel och app-connections.
När produkten väl var på hyllorna så drog de tillbaka hela tänket, hela allting som skulle bygga hela det här konceptet.
Det blev en total katastrof.
Även det bolaget gick i kurs och lämnade oss med enorma problem som vi sedan fick lösa igenom genom att ha bra öppen kommunikation.
Det tog också runt ett och ett halvt år innan vi var ut ur den.
Det var nog en av huvudanledningarna till att vi ens överlevde.
Vi köpte oss tid men vi kände att det här kan gå åt helvete.
Det var precis vad det gjorde.
Två produkter där egentligen den själva tekniken och produkten inte var något fel på, utan det var skit bakom spakarna på annat sätt.
Man kan ju känna att ni har blivit lite påverkade av det eller lite försiktiga.
Vi har ju gjort några sådana, inte tabbar, utan det är bara liksom sådant som händer, men där vi har tagit hem någon container, det har varit något fel eller det har varit en produkt som inte säljer.
Det är jag lite påverkad av så att vi, nu för tiden gör vi ju ofta så att vi tar hem en produkt och så testar vi den i lite mindre volymer och sen om det går bra under några månader, då trycker vi på.
Men går ni mer på magkänsla eller är ni lite försiktiga?
Vi gillar ju att vara lite bold ändå.
Jag skulle inte säga att vi är så försiktiga.
Sen är det kanske lite, vi jobbar ju inte med några owned brands i den bemärkelsen.
Däremot, det här varumärket Reclaim då, som är ett svenskeverkat fettmedel med en synfritt som tar bort lukt och det är inriktad mot lite olika delar.
Det är förut min fru driver det bolaget i koncernen.
Men i övrigt så har vi inte några egna varumärken i den delen och det tror jag minimerar våran risk lite grann skulle jag säga.
För vi har ju alltid våra leverantörer att luta oss mot, skulle någonting hända, blir det en återkallning eller något annat, då vet vi att vi får den hjälpen.
Om de inte går ut konkurs då.
Det har ju hänt.
Men jag skulle inte säga att vi är superförsiktiga i det, utan vi försöker väl alltid hålla en sund nivå.
Vi försöker titta på lite förorder, sen tar vi alltid höjd för vad vi tror ska vara den spontana försäljningen som sker, utan några förordelser och bitar.
Har ni en sådan uppdelning då, som en riskdiversifierad aktieportfölj där ett innehav får inte bli för stort, eller trycker ni bara på och ser vart det hamnar?
Vi trycker på skulle jag säga.
Det är inte så att vi någonsin har begränsat någonting, men däremot så lever vi i en väldigt konfortabel värld, givet att inget varumärke vi har idag är större än 19% av omsättningen.
Och likadant, ingen kund är större än 7%, vilket gör att vi har en tårt diagram som är väldigt skönt.
Normalt sett i vår bransch sitter vi inte med en kund som kanske står för 40% av omsättningen eller liknande 45%.
Det är L-leverantörer, men där är vi inte, och det känns väldigt skönt.
Men det har sagt inte att vi aktivt jobbar mot att låta något varumärke booma ordentligt.
Då har man ju ett positivt problem.
Jag kan ju ändå ha någon sorts uppfattning för vad ett e-handelsbolag har för personal och vad personal sitter med.
Jag kan liksom förstå vad som är personalintensivt på en Ica-butik, men inom distributörsvärlden, vad har man för personal och vad gör folk på dagarna?
Ja men det är ju väl som alla andra bolag, det här är ju någonting som ligger mig väldigt, väldigt varmt om hjärtat.
Att bygga en fin företagskultur.
Det har jag brunnit, även när jag drev det dansk-ägda bolaget, så ville jag driva det på mitt sätt.
Det fick jag göra så länge som jag presterade.
Men för oss här, alla som är här, är här för att de tycker att det är roligt att vara här.
Jag tror att vi är 22 anställda i den nordiska verksamheten här uppe.
Och jag tror vi är sex eller sju som har varit här mer än tio år.
Och den absoluta majoriteten av resten har varit här mer än fem år.
Jag tror att vi...
Jag tror på att ge man så får man.
Och det tycker jag har visat sig vara ändå ganska tydligt att det fungerar.
Sen måste det såklart, det beror helt på hur verksamheten ser ut.
Vi har en skalbar verksamhet, vi kan addera hundra miljoner i omsättning utan att vi behöver utöka personalstyrkan.
I princip, det tjänar sig med en.
Men vi har en skalbar verksamhet och det är inte alla som har det.
Så jag tycker att det viktigaste för min del, det är, som jag tror att många andra gör ett misstag i, det är att för mig så är de anställda den största tillgången för oss.
Och jag tror att väljer man att se det på det sättet så tror jag att man har ett väldigt väl fungerande maskineri, om alla kan hantera det.
Det är väldigt mycket om och män här, jag hör ju det, men samtidigt så är det.
Får man en bra människa så kan jag jobba under eget ansvar.
Vi går inte in i något micromanagement.
Vi är ett ägare eller ett bolag.
Det kan många gånger skrämma bort många anställda för då tror man att vi är inne och petar i allt.
Vi är verkligen inte inne och petar i allt, vi har en ledningsgrupp som är oerhört kompetent och de har, vi har satt en strategi och vi vill driva saker och ting och det gör de på ett alldeles ypperligt sätt.
Vi har ett exempel, det här med friarbetsstid, det hade vi långt innan covid, så när covid slog till, det var liksom inte någon dramatik här.
Alla har alltid kunnat jobba från där de vill.
Nu har vi lite strukturerat som gör att vi gärna ser att folk är måndagar, vad blir det nu, måndagar, onsdagar och torsdagar, tisdag och fredagar och vill man vara hemma de övriga dagarna så går det också bra.
Men man har några dagar där man känner att man ändå vill kunna samlas och ta de mötena som behövs.
Och torsdagar börjar vi med i ledningsgruppen och turas om och gör en ordentlig fin frukost.
Och sedan 11.30 så har vi ett fullstort gym där vi har lite används och lite showroom också, men där finns de maskinerna som behövs och de bitarna.
Så 11.30 kör vi varje torsdag ett gruppträningspass.
Och de som är med på tränningen bjuder vi på lunch.
Sedan används gymmet i princip varje dag här utanom anställda, vilket också är uppskattat liksom.
Men vi har ett vinstdelningsprogram som gör att når vi fram gemensamt så faller det ut en extra månadslön till alla.
Alla driver mot samma mål.
Vi åker alltid iväg med samtliga anställda.
Det är väldigt viktigt att ingen lämnas hemma på olika kickoffer runtom i Europa, tillsammans med några av våra tillverkare, där vi har oftast fyra nätter och fyra-fem dagar där vi har väldigt bra sessions där vi går igenom.
Nu läger framtid, strategier, det skapas bondningar som är helt fantastiska.
Förra året var vi i Marokko, nu i oktober i år så ska vi ner till Kreta.
Det binder mycket och det skapar en atmosfär som är väldigt härligt.
Jag tror på den.
Jag tror på att man ska jobba mycket mer med de bitarna.
Måste man vara så god som arbetsgivare jämt?
Jag tror att det är något som sticker ut idag.
Jag tror att många gånger så problemen till en dålig arbetsmiljö på arbetsplatsen, jag tror på riktigt att det beror på att det finns för många mellan chefer som har egna agender, 100 procent, och framförallt i icke-ägareledda bolag.
Det är ju så de flesta arbetsplatser ser ut.
Jag tror på riktigt att det är rätt att gå.
För mig är det det.
Vi ska inte gå in och säga att man godhetsknarkar på något sätt, men återigen tittar vi på vår resa och ser, det har varit oerhört transparenta när det har gått åt helvete för oss.
Då berättar vi det för alla.
Vad som händer då är att vi får alla med oss.
Nu ska vi klara detta tillsammans.
Likväl som att när det går väldigt bra så vet alla att det går väldigt bra.
Vi gömmer inga siffror, vi himlar inte med någonting.
Vi är väldigt öppna i de bitarna.
Jag tror att det är nog ganska unikt idag.
Alla får driva sina bolag på det sätt de vill, men jag tror på riktigt att detta är rätt väg att gå.
Så länge det inte missbrukas, för det är inte alla som kan hantera friheter och en sådan här tillvaro vi har här.
Nu svarar inte jag alls på din fråga, vad alla gör här.
Men det man kan säga är att vi har ju som alla andra, vi har en ekonomiadelning, vi har en marknadsavdelning, vi har en ikom-avdelning, vi har en inköpsavdelning.
Däremot är vi inte så många på varje, för vi täcker upp ganska bra på de olika områdena med den styrkan som vi har.
Sen har vi ett säljteam som är spritt lite grann över Norden.
Sen har vi en kammuppe i Eskistuna och en tjej som sitter och driver.
Vårt hållbarhetsarbete och även kundkontakter uppe i Norden utgår från Åre.
Så har vi vår manager för Finland som utgår från Helsingfors och har vi två stycken anställda nere i Köpnamn.
Så det är lite spridda skurar på säljsidan och har några säljare som utgår härifrån också.
Men vi har ju lite liknande som är där att folk får välja lite sina egna tider och så där.
Jag har läst mycket om det.
Jag gillar din, vi är ganska lika ändå i det sättet.
Förutom att du, jag försöker att trycka mer på att, jag läste ditt inlägg om frukorgar och de vidare, du vill inte ha några fasta kostnader här och det är en ganska intressant aspekt.
Jag tror att den är någon.
Jag drar ojärna in, när det är jävligt tufft, så drar jag ojärna in på saker.
Jag försöker få alla till att sälja mer eller hitta vägar för att få en större omsättning egentligen.
Ja men det jag tänker någonstans är ju att, om man är liksom schysst som person, vilket ju är beundransvärt men då är man ju liksom schysst och så låter man det vara behagligt liksom.
Men hur balanserar man upp det?
Hur bibehåller man produktiviteten där någonstans år tolv utan att det blir lalligt liksom?
Det är en bra fråga också.
Jag upplever inte att det är lalligt.
Jag upplever att vi, så länge jag och Martin tycker att det är det roligaste vi vet, så tror jag att det känns.
Det smittar av sig och det...
Egentligen idag har vi inte några affärskritiska ansvarsområden längre.
Jag och Martin.
Det har du också pratat om tidigare och jag har läst om att är det det man vill med ett bolag att göra sig obehöv?
Men obehöv är inte samma sak som att...
Eller rättare sagt att jag är här och håller de övergripande delarna.
Jag är ju fortfarande här även ifall det inte är affärskritiskt.
Sen tror jag helt övertygad om jag skulle försvinna i tre månader så hade den här verksamheten eller Martin fortsatt på precis samma sätt.
Sen är ju frågan om då, det är alltid där.
Men vart ska vi höja blicken och de bitarna?
Det på något sätt hade kanske stagnerat då.
För det är klart att det måste ju finnas någon som tar den taktpinnen.
Men nej, jag skulle inte säga att vi är åt det viset ett jävla kompetent gäng.
Jag är ju emot möten också i stort.
Jag tycker att man ska inte ha för mycket möten.
Möten behövs men de måste vara begränsade.
Eller begränsade, inte begränsande.
Och jag tror att det har vi också lyckats hålla på en väldigt balanserad nivå skulle jag säga.
Så nej, vi har inget lallande här.
Så länge jag...
Det är också så här, men nu har vi gjort detta i 13 år.
Vad ska vi göra?
Ska vi fortsätta göra detta 13 år till?
Ja, just nu känns det som om det precis har börjat.
Vi har så mycket roligt som ändar och det är så mycket bra grejer som vi har i vår pipeline.
Och det här, vad fan, vad ska jag göra annars?
Det är den här tanken bara för att vi har lyckats att driva upp det här.
Jag kan ju inte titulera mig världsmästare och bygga bolag.
Vi har lyckats med det här och det har nog att göra med både, det är en kombination av allt möjligt, det är timing och det är timing, tur, erfarenhet och skicklighet i en tombola.
Sen innebär det inte att man klarar att göra det igen på ett annat sätt.
Vi får se vart det tar väga men just nu känns det bara att det är fortsatt väldigt, väldigt roligt.
Jag kan uppleva att folk lägger någon sorts...
Jag bara tänker, börja om, börja om en gång till, de här första åren, det kan ju vara fint att nostalgiskt tänka tillbaka på men de är inte så jävla sköna alltså.
Nej men det hade väl nog inte blivit på det sättet tänker jag.
Att göra det som vi gjorde, vi är ju superstoltade att vi har lyckats komma hit med den lilla, förhållandevis lilla insatsen som vi ändå la in i början.
Det har varit en enorm resa vi har gjort där och det skulle man inte göra på samma sätt igen tror jag, utan då hade man ju på något sätt, om man har en idé, ja då hade man ju sjösat den med lite mer kapital, lite mer att man dundrar igång direkt snarare än att man bygger det här.
Först är vi två, sen är vi tre, sen är vi fyra.
Vi har byggt hela den organisationen organiskt fram till där vi är idag.
Likadant våra dotter, bolagsverksamheter har ju faktiskt ändå varit husat lönsamma sen start.
Det tar lång tid att bygga innan det börjar bli, men nu börjar Frankriket bli väldigt bra.
Benelux börjar också ta sig på ett riktigt bra sätt, men det tar tid.
De har varit igång i sex och sju år där nere.
Men nej, jag tror inte att man...
Jag vet inte.
Jag vet ju själv inte vad jag ska bli när jag blir stor.
Fan.
I och med att både jag och Charlotte Frugan jobbar med det här tillsammans.
Vi har varit ihop i 23 år.
Vi har en härlig tillvaro för det gör att vi kan jobba från vad vi vill när vi vill.
Vi älskar resa.
Det skapar en möjlighet till att ha det ganska bra i de bitarna.
Det kan vara rätt skönt nu efter de första 8, 9, 10 riktigt tuffa åren.
Jag kan känna att det är...
Det finns ingenstans som jag är så avslappnad.
Folk säger att man ska koppla bort teknik och system när man har borta resor.
Det finns ingen gång som jag är så glad och nöjd och tacksam och avstressad så när jag på eftermiddagen får checka in och logga in i affärssystemet, då blir jag lugn.
Får jag inte göra det då blir jag stressad som fan.
Morgon, någon gång där mellan 7.30 och 8.00, det är min lugnaste stund på veckan.
Bara sitta ner och bara stämma av allt som var från förra veckan.
Ja det är underbart.
När man har varit i mycket resveckor och sådana grejer och bara priser och säger Få måndagen på plats, det är underbart, det är skönt.
Jag tänker att jag kör någon sorts lite knepig slutfråga här, men det är väldigt mycket diskussion här i senaste perioden om att kunden kommer ju närmare producenten.
Finns det en inneboende konflikt där mellan återförsäljare och distributör?
Och jag säger inte att det nätverket ska försvinna i nästan fem år, men på 50 års sikt, tänker jag.
Ja, det skulle jag väl tro.
Det är så svårt, det händer så mycket hela tiden på de här bitarna.
På något sätt, vi har inte hamnat i någon, vi har varit öppna och tydliga med att vi har börjat driva våra vårmärkers e-handelsplattformar för Norden.
Hade det varit för tio år sen så hade det inte sett sig med bida ögon på något sätt.
Men idag är det en del av strategin för oss att bygga varumärken.
Vi kommer aldrig att lägga hela vår energi på att bygga ICOM-delen.
Det är snarare en servicegrad.
Vår business idag, det är tillsammans med vår åtkälare att hitta bra vägar och bra strategier framöver.
Jag tror ändå att, speciellt i Norden där marketplaces inte riktigt, det existerar ju knappt inte, det finns ju, men det är väldigt lite.
Tittar du på England, Frankrike, Tyskland, där är ju marketplaces enormt stora.
Men det är också, det visar ju tydligt att vi är väldigt trogna, våra traditionella inköpskanaler.
Annars hade det varit en mycket större impact från Amazon och allt annat, vilket det än så länge ändå inte är i Sverige.
För vi värnar om att kunna få lokal hjälp och lokal...
Så jag tror att den är väldigt välsementerad, jag tror att det är någon annanstans i övriga Europa, där det kommer gå ännu fortare åt andra hållet, men jag tror att Norden är, där är vi i ett annat läge tror jag.
Kommer inte varumärken, vilja liksom sortera bort ett led, för att kunna slåss prismässigt mot andra varumärken?
Jo, det tror jag att vi kommer att se en, där är det nog en större del.
Tittar man på Swift som blivit en konkurrent också, det är ju lite grötigt där liksom mellan, och de Swift går ju direkt och säljer hårdvara mot slutkonsumenter.
Det är klart att kuttar du två led så har du ju en helt annan prispill på det.
Så det är klart att vi kommer nog se mer av den typen av problematik.
Sen är det mycket som händer geopolitiskt nu.
Tittar man på USA, vad som händer där borta med alla tullkrig och de bitarna, jag tror att det är många varumärken som blickar bort från USA.
Och kanske titta på som inte varit så intresserade att bygga varumärken i Europa tidigare som börjar göra det nu.
Så där tror jag vi har en möjlighet att växa den delen.
Men det är så svårt, det händer så och det är bara att titta, vad fan, hur länge har Trump varit på och hur mycket har hänt under den här perioden.
Och hela Tesla står med Musk och hans involvering där.
Jag menar det är ingen som kan säga om framtiden idag, så kan man säga.
Men det är intressant och det är kul, att se vart vi är på väg.
Det händer mycket.
Om jag nu ska ändå be dig säga om framtiden här, och kanske inte för er resultat och liknande utan mer liksom, kan du säga att det finns vissa varumärken ni rör er mot eller någon viss trend som ni rör er mot på marknaden?
Nej, men vi har en ganska brem punchline till våra.
Vi har ju Connecting Life with technology, vilket gör att vi tittar på allt som kan göra din vardag enklare och som kan göra den uppkopplad mer eller mindre på ett sätt som hjälper dig fram, oavsett om det är i träning eller i vardagen.
Men hela det, det blir grötigt att säga, men det är ju klart att det är ju inom detta som nästa stora, the big thing kommer att vara.
Ja, det är ju vissa scenarion som vi ser framför oss och som vi jobbar mot som jag inte kan liksom yppa här, men där vi tror att det finns ändå en rimlig chans inom liksom en inte alltför lång framtid att det skulle kunna ske.
Så det är både befintliga varumärken, men också kanske varumärken som kommer att etablera sig på den nordiska marknaden eller den europeiska och lite sådant.
Så vi håller ju hela tiden ögonen på vad som händer.
Det är färre och färre från Europa Norden som åker till Vegas-mässan, men vi anser att det fortsatt är väldigt viktigt att vara där, det är viktigt att synas, det är viktigt att visa att vi är där och de kontakterna som är där är väldigt, väldigt bra att träffa.
Det ger alltid någonting.
Det är liksom, det öppnas dörrar där man minst armar det.
Men man måste, man får aldrig slappna av liksom.
Man kan aldrig sitta ner och vara fettenhäppig.
Det är det största, det är det värsta man kan göra.
Man måste vara på tårna hela tiden, för man är aldrig safe liksom.
Det kan hända vad som helst.
Och vi har ju varit med om det.
Det är konkurser och det kan vara, det kan bli bolag som blir uppköpta och som ändrar sin strategi eller som går på sina kort som tidigare har fungerat för dem.
Så att vi är aldrig som sitter i det läget som vi gör som distributörer.
Vi kan aldrig sitta och vara safe.
Men så därför är det viktigt, vi är på tårna hela tiden.
Daniel, ett stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Vilken jävla story du betar av och vilket bolag ni har byggt.
Otroligt inspirerande och tack för att jag fick sitta och lyssna.
Ja, tack så hjärtligt.
Hehehehe Kristoffer, du som sitter och klipper detta nu, du jobbar ju hos oss.
Dra nu inte för stora växlar av detta.
Vi kanske får vänta lite innan vi drar till Marokko.
Jag tänker att vi kör en skede med busstur i några år till.